We are continuing to follow the 2022
midterms last week we um looked at both
the Democratic and Republican primary
debates in the Pennsylvania Senate race
we will be looking at another debate in
that race Wednesday night I will be
streaming the Republicans including
Mehmet Oz and a bunch of other wackos
are going to be debating and we'll be
covering that live but today I want to
talk a little bit about Georgia Georgia
has a number of interesting races and
they involve significant controversy in
Georgia you've got the gubernatorial
election
um in that uh that that is an important
race because of the role that Georgia
played in 2020 and could play in 2024 in
the election and who is governor and
Secretary of State a very big deal a
Marjorie Taylor green at this point
wildly perjuring herself inciting an
Insurrection she is involved in a race
for re-election and there are debates
happening there as well and what I want
you to think about as you watch some of
these clips there were a number of
Georgia debates over the weekend we'll
look at gubernatorial we will look at
also uh Marjorie Taylor green
um they seem like Saturday Night Live
skits and I'm not just talking about the
accents I know people in Georgia in
certain parts there's a certain
education level where there's a certain
accent that that's not what I'm talking
about these seem like characters out of
a skit
where we are pretending to be the most
weaponized disinformed caricatures of
what it means to be an American right
winger when we think of how do you
depict your typical American right
winger in a film for a British audience
it would be like these people let's go
with the first clip this is Candace
Taylor running for the uh Georgia
Governor's race and
um I I let's just listen I won't even
tell there's no there's really no way to
introduce this properly take a look put
the Constitution first and I'm going to
put Jesus first every single time wait G
you're you're guiding philosophy will be
Jesus first you're supposed to be a
representative of the state's civil
government which is a separation of
church and state but she openly says
Jesus will be number one for her and
we're going to fix our souls we're going
to get rid of this anti-white racism and
oppression of our children of color
we're gonna get and again children is
that is that a normal thing I don't want
to make fun of accents but are these do
is that is that a normal thing children
three out of a transgender manipulation
and we're going to ensure that boys are
in our girls bathrooms and girls are in
our boys bathrooms and people aren't
being raped and we're going to get rid
of kindergarten teachers men with beers
and lipstick and high heels teaching our
children we're going to get back to
being moral in Georgia we're going to
put morality over money I'm Candace
Taylor I'm the one you've been waiting
for right that is dark age's stuff and
is it even okay to say know sometimes
people get mad when you say Dark Ages
but that that's that's Dark Age of stuff
that's retrograde that's taking us back
to you know sometimes we say they want
to take us to 1955 with some of these
people it's almost like they want to
take us to 1855. United States uh here's
another clip of Candace Taylor talking
about uh what was going on all of the
bad things about schools having been
closed for a period of time during the
covet pandemic you do as governor what
would you push to help address those
issues dealing with academics
absolutely it's gotten way worse because
of the plant pandemic because our
governor opened the state which was
great they didn't open the school now
did she say the planned pandemic I want
to go back because that that's another
wild conspiracy this is almost like
remember the the disinformation film
pandemic which argued it was all planned
by the globalist elite as Alex Jones
would say thinly veiled anti-Semitism by
the way because the the those
globalished Elite happened to be mostly
Jewish
um did she say the planned pandemic let
me listen way worse because of the plant
pandemic because our government maybe it
was just a stutter it could it's almost
like she said the planned pandemic let's
listen and our open estate which was
great they didn't open the schools and
so kids were at home for a year not
ingrained in education and routine
children need routine and what we saw
happen is children with depression or
children were being molested let's talk
about the hard stuff kids are being
molested never had had a reprieve they
were molested day after day after day
and her parents were not teaching them
anything and so staying consistent for
one thing and after and after school
programs and offering things to get them
yeah now I mean it is it is absolutely
true that
one of the things about being stuck at
home and we saw this with couples where
there's domestic violence oftentimes
leaving to work was when you got a break
from the domestic violence that that is
true but this sort of framing
completely ignoring the actual
circumstances that were happening
medically imagine this is the governor
very very dangerous next we'll go to
from the Georgia gubernatorial to
Georgia 14th District there was a
Republican primary debate the incumbent
in that seat is radical repugnant
reactionary Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green and she was in a
debate with Jennifer Strahan
and her behavior was so childish and so
absurd that the moderator actually had
to cut her Mike because she just
wouldn't stop talking Marjorie Taylor
green would not stop talking
conservative it takes courage takes
bravery to vote no to bills that have
poison pills inside of them and things
that should never be passed and that's
how the Democrats running Congress
that's how they're writing bills right
now and that is why with another record
I have let me just mentioned
we don't get a rebuttal no you would
have voted
transgender surgeries okay oh wow and
then just uh but the the relief of the
silence when Marjorie Taylor Greene
stopped speaking it's like you know when
it it's like you're on a loud concert
and it's just like wow this is this is
grading this is grading and then all of
a sudden it goes silent and you go wow
the the Tranquility the Tranquility sir
of the silence um that is what I
experience when Marjorie Taylor green
stops talking so that was totally off
the rails and then also in the um
Congressional debate a guy named Eric
Cunningham is running and he tries to
deliver a statement about he will also
out Jesus everybody else but he weirdly
like loses his train of thought and just
seems visibly confused they're not
sending their best my friends Cunningham
I have strong core Christian
conservative values and I want to
emphasize one word and they're Christian
it's my faith that brought me into this
race and it's my faith that will lead me
when I go to Congress to to fight some
of the woke
transgender you name it
um
agenda that they have they're trying to
force on us so he seems confused by his
own ideas and of course at this point
these are just these these are just
buzzwords uh woke we're gonna fight woke
we're gonna fight transgender we're
gonna fight we do teacher Trump now at
his rally saying teachers shouldn't be
allowed to teach transgender
grammatically ambiguous for sure uh
morally morally depraved too so it's
actually the the 2022 midterms are
ramping up so quickly it's actually
tough to keep track I also wanted to
look at some clips from what's going on
in Arizona in some of the primary races
there some of these primaries are this
week by the way and we'll talk about
that tomorrow Tuesday but no shortage of
cuckoo for Coco Puffs people that
unfortunately I'd love to say these
people have no shot but Marjorie Taylor
green is in Congress now so we know they
have a shot
let me know who you're most worried
about you can find me on Twitter at
dpacman
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
I've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when I use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say I'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up I can delete that virtual
card so I know I'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say I'm
ordering food over the phone but I left
my wallet somewhere I don't have my real
credit card on me I can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is you're not out there
exposing your real credit card number so
you're not as susceptible to data
breaches and identity theft privacy C is
a totally free service and you'll get
five bucks to spend when you go to
privacy.com Pacman the link is right
underneath this video